yeah so I think since I'm one of the
organizers I'll actually take the
opportunity to thank all the speakers
and all of you for attending it's been a
lot of fun to hear the wide range of
perspectives and topics this week and of
course also thanks to the Simons
Institute for for hosting us the date I
noticed is wrong here actually obviously
it's November 20th not October 20th
I haven't been sleeping much lately so
so I'm gonna I think in the interest of
time I'm gonna skip over some of the
introductory material here we've heard a
lot about ride-sharing platforms already
so let me just skip that I think at this
point in the week between the the talk
that was given by Christos Co on Monday
and then also the industrial visitors
day we had last week we all are familiar
with uber and lyft and sidecar and
platforms like this so what's our goal
in our work oh and I should actually
start preface this by saying this is
joint work with Sid Banerjee who's an
assistant professor at Cornell he was
doing a postdoc with me and Carlos
raqami who's a student of mine at
Stanford and also Sid did an internship
with lyft and with their data science
team and so some of the inspiration for
this work came from from talking and
working with them so I guess what but
I'm interested in getting across to you
and what I found exciting about this
problem is that there was a combination
of maybe three things that we needed to
somehow include in one model and and
then use that to actually say something
useful about the you know the strategy
that the platform takes and that's
basically that there's passengers and
drivers who are strategic the platform
is setting you know a pricing rule a
decision for how transaction prices are
set on each on each interaction and then
there's this kind of underlying queueing
dynamic that governs you know the number
of rides that are requested and the
number of drivers that are available and
in isolation we have a lot of you know
different models and in various
literature's that tell us about any one
of these three problems one of the
things that makes us really interesting
to me is the fact that all three kind of
come together in one place so this would
just be I think you know a pure
theoretical exercise it would be fun to
build a model of something like that now
of course you want to do that with some
purpose in mind in our case the
motivation for wanting to do this in the
first place is that we sort of wanted to
try to understand what the advantages
were of using a dynamic pricing policy
over static price
policy and I'll explain more what I mean
by that as we go on so I'll skip this
side as well I just want to briefly
point out that there's a wide range of
literature in very different communities
actually that touches on this so at the
same time that you know we've been
thinking about matching markets whether
an econ or in in the UC community it's
been interesting to see in the applied
probability community there's been a
huge amount a huge surge of interest in
models of queuing systems with matching
behavior and so I think you know for
those of you that are working on
matching markets I would strongly
recommend sort of looking into some of
the some of the work that I think really
starts with the Donna and bison goes
from there there's a lot of work on
strategic queuing models two-sided
platforms revenue management so like I
said you know there's there's a lot
there and and and and one of the things
that made this fun is sitting at an
intersection of those of those topics
okay so let me tell you a bit about the
model so the model is something where we
need to capture three features so one is
that I need to be able to say something
about you know the platform's goals
right you know how is it setting a
pricing policy I need to be able to tell
you what the incentives are of
passengers and what the incentives are
our drivers and that's all sort of the
strategic aspect of the model I also
want to be able to tell you you know
exactly even fixing all of this you know
how how does the system evolve what are
the dynamics of drivers and passengers
okay so some an apology I want to
interject here is that I think this is a
talk
I personally view as sort of at the tip
of a very large iceberg and in many ways
I think the work that we were doing
raises more questions than it answers so
I'm happy with some of the answers we
got but I also want to be very kind of
explicit with you where I think there's
important things missing okay
so some of them are on this slide and
some of them all mentioned as we go
through so one of them is that we're
gonna focus on just a single block of
time and what do I mean by a block I
mean something like let's say rush hour
or you know maybe for those of you that
were here for Christmas goes talk a
block of time might be you know a window
of time around when bars close on a
Friday or Saturday evening so why is
that important in many ways what I want
to focus on here is not I want to avoid
talking about predictable changes in
demand
okay so everybody
knows there's going to be more demand
around rush hour than there is in the
afternoon alright so I want to avoid
that and indeed the platform's avoid
that so even even before surge pricing
became sort of something which is
changing at a minute-to-minute basis you
know it was the case that they would
know in advance that there's going to be
greater demand let's say around rush
hour or bars closing and and the the
surge market multiplier would be higher
in those intervals so when I talk about
static pricing I don't mean a fixed
price over the entire week I mean static
over something like you know a few hours
a block of time okay the next thing is
in the talk I'm only going to focus on a
single region now of course you know
cities are not just a single region and
I think even Chris on Monday mentioned
that you know the pricing involves
multiple neighborhoods in in the work
that we've done in the paper we do have
the main insights that we have do
generalized to networks there's some
sort of exceptions to that but I'm not
going to devolve that in the talk I
think one important problem that my
focusing on a single region completely
ignores and even the work on networks
completely ignores is I guess there's
two issues that that that sort of
eliminates right so one is the notion of
an estimated time arrival or ETA and I
think as you heard from Chris and as
anyone who actually uses uber or lyft
would know you know in addition to
whether or not their search pricing
you're very sensitive to when you think
you're actually going to get a ride note
so what the ETA actually is so sort of
by fixing the network and you'll see
more in the models sort of how this
plays out now one of the things we don't
actually have much to say about is how
passengers are sensitive to etas and
sort of in particular you know one thing
that might mean is that the design of
the regions themselves like what you
consider to be a region is not a topic
that we address at all right so you so
you may want to make your regions more
granular so that you're able to better
you know acclimatize a better match
supply and demand on a very local scale
but as you do that you will also want to
make sure that drivers who are nearby
are able to move in or out okay so we're
not really we're not really accounting
for those effects in the kinds of
network model that we build and I think
so so thinking about ETA s and and how
the platform actually designs
you know designs it's it's topology I
think that's I think that's a really
interesting direction of work it's
something sedan I've talked about we
haven't really done much with it yet and
find the last thing I'll mention is the
objective function I'm going to focus on
is is throughput the rate of completed
rides
there's at least three objectives that
you you know might care about there's
throughput there's profit and then
there's welfare so we we have results
for throughput that sort of have no
qualification whatsoever we have results
for profit when the system is supplied
limited in a sense I'll make precise and
then there's similar numerical results
for welfare but the theory there is
actually a bit more challenging and so
I'm not going to claim anything for that
in the talk okay so let me start by
modeling sort of the strategic side of
the problem and this is another point
which we'd say you know very little
about we don't say anything in our paper
on and I think it's an interesting issue
is that we're going to just assert that
the platform takes a fixed fraction of
every dollar that's spent and you know I
think that's fairly consistent with how
the platform's work today but it's kind
of interesting I mean it's a mechanism
designer you might actually think this
is one of the very first things you
would want to design you'd want to
optimize over so our work does not
optimize over this it kind of holds that
as an exogenous constant I think one of
the most interesting things to do is to
kind of a lot of questions during
chrises talk on Monday I think alluded
to this that it's interesting to think
about whether the platform should be
sort of varying the the share that it
takes perhaps you know based on the
state of the system there's a good
reasons why most platforms don't really
change this on a very fast timescale you
know I mean this is the type of thing
that would be updated you know over
months or something like that if at all
and it's really a I think I think it's
it's more of a sort of cultural issue
right i mean i think i think drivers and
passengers are not drivers would not be
very happy if they if they kind of were
subject to to a rapidly varying share of
earnings it becomes very unpredictable
from their perspective of course the
platform needs both drivers and
passengers and it uses pricing to align
the two sides one note on terminology in
the platform's literature you know in
economics if you use the word pricing
you have to be a little clearer about
you means so pricing might mean the fee
structure which is the gamaheer for
example or pricing might mean actually
setting the transaction price and one of
the reasons that ride-sharing
platforms were fun to think about in
contrast to other kinds of platforms
that I find interesting is because they
actually directly set the transaction
price so that like that's why this is an
interesting question you know if you
come compare that with something like
let's say op work or Airbnb they have a
lot of influence on what the transaction
prices might be like but they don't
actually directly set them okay so here
when I use the word pricing I actually
mean the platform is setting the
transaction price and so they're able to
use their mechanism for setting the
transaction price to align the two sides
so the first bit of notation is that the
way I'm going to model the platform
setting the transaction price is just as
a function of the number of available
drivers remember I'm focused on only one
region there's a number of available
drivers right now in that region I'll
imagine there's some function that the
platform uses to map the number of
available drivers to the price that
you're going to get charged if you if
you take a ride right now okay all right
next qualifier so when I say price you
know I'm saying you're setting the
transaction price and again it's not
directly the transaction price that's
being set in in the ride-sharing
platforms it's a multiplier on the
transact on a base price okay so the way
these platforms are work they'll have a
published formula that's time and
distance dependant that's on their
website and if you use a fare estimator
you can actually directly calculate this
so that's what they call the base price
and any price manipulation that's
happening on a faster time scale is
happening through a multiplier once the
lift calls it prime time pricing uber
calls it surge pricing and so you know
what's happening is that they will they
will tell you that there's some
percentage that's going to get added on
top of the base price because of that
sort of current state of the market so
when I use the word price in the talk
what I'm really talking about is this
multiplier okay that raises yet another
interesting question which is of course
you know Los Angeles and San Francisco
are very different markets and in Los
Angeles in particular you know there may
be a very large cost to pulling drivers
from you know that look available from
further away to come pick up a ride and
that ride you know that cost as part of
a distance dependent so these kinds of
things you know it's often a question
that comes up here is well why is this
also not a matter of manipulation not
just a multiplier on type on top of a
formula but why not actually just
directly be sort of manipulating prices
in a way that that you're not just
picking a single multiplier regardless
of what the time
the distance is going to be and again
something I'm not touching I think this
is another one of those things just
thinking about from regulatory
perspective you know ride-sharing
platforms are fighting against the taxi
industry and that's you know the taxi
sort of industry has you know published
fare schedules like this it's already
challenging enough to convince the
public that you know surge pricing or
primetime pricing is palatable I find
that shocking I have to confess but that
that's the way it is so given that
that's hard enough I think varying this
is also going to be you know politically
even more difficult but that's said from
a you know market design standpoint I
think it's a reasonable question to ask
okay so that's the platform yeah
multiplier number of available drivers
yes I'm gonna have a model where the
state of the system is the number of
available drivers and this doesn't do
that that's right yeah I think there's a
lot of different things that are being
left out here so that's part of it and
as you're gonna see in a second in I'm
taking in my talk in extreme view where
drivers are making entry decisions over
longer time skills now if you think
about some of the tools that platforms
are using and and you know Chris talked
about some of these on Monday
another thing that's left out here is
not just sort of the number of available
drivers right now but let's say a
forecast that I have of how many
available drivers there will be all that
kind of stuff is just left out of it I
think there's a lot of interesting
things to do there in terms of the
richness of the pricing policy okay so
with the passengers
what do passengers do act fairly simple
model of passengers every passenger is
one ride so passenger equals one ride
request I don't model any sort of
longitudinal behavior of the passenger
it's just simple and basically I'm just
gonna model the passengers as entering
if their price exceeds if their
reservation value exceeds the current
price in the system okay so to model
that I think of every every ride request
is being drawn iid from some valuation
distribution and if if the value that's
drawn is bigger than the current price
they enter there's some eggs agenda
straight of what I'll call app opens
Chris talked about the same thing and
that's basically like I open the app and
looked
do I want to request a ride and then
look at the price and determine whether
I actually request a ride so from that
it's pretty easy to work out based on
the pricing you know formula what is the
rate of ride requests it's the exogenous
rate times the tail probability that the
valuation exceeds the the current price
okay so this F bar is the tail tail CDF
of the evaluation distribution right so
that's the passengers it's relatively
simple the drivers I think is where it
gets a little bit more interesting this
is maybe the one place where our
motivation for choosing this model kind
of came from what what seemed to us to
be like a natural distinction between
drivers and passengers I would say that
I think of this as kind of a stylized
extreme point and there you know
especially as the platform's changed the
technology that they use to induce
drivers to enter or exit I think we can
get we can bisque and get a lot more
interesting but let me tell you what
this is basically the point that that we
make here is that we think of drivers is
making decisions on just a substantively
different time scale than passengers
okay so if a driver is thinking about
whether to drive for example in the
early days of lyft
you know you had like a booking calendar
when you would essentially say like when
you wanted to be on or off the platform
and the time interval over which you
were choosing to drive or not is
probably something on the order of hours
and so essentially what we do is we say
well kind of from a driver's perspective
they're not responding to the
instantaneous state of the system
instead what they're thinking is if I
enter what's the expected earnings that
that I'll receive if I'm if I'm part of
the platform and what they do is they
compare the expected earnings they'll
make while they're in the system to
essentially be expected you know the
kind of a reservation earnings that they
want to reservation earnings rate okay
this is also really interesting so this
is kind of a target earning model of the
driver like basically they have some
fixed mental model of how much they want
to be able to make and they enter if it
exceeds that you know I think Chris
pointed to examples of a lot of
different driver behavior in their data
and you know you would certainly see
that across all the platforms so I think
that's that's a that's a really
interesting direction also first of all
just do you have the right kind of
utility model for drivers I think this
is when I say you know when I say that
we're taking an extreme point what I
mean is this time scale separation
between drivers and passengers is a
fundamental part of the model it would
be interesting to think about what
starts happening
if drivers are responding more directly
to instantaneous state and in particular
I think the the way this comes together
with the network's comment earlier is if
I'm able to provide signals to drivers
that say this is a place where I think
demand is locally higher than supply and
what I'm doing is I want to induce
drivers to move in that direction and
when I'm trading off the effects I'm
trading off are that it takes drivers
time to move to a new area it takes
drivers away from the area that they
were in you know so I sort of I think
that that's that's really where the the
network modeling gets gets especially
interesting so that's kind of one of the
things that we want to keep doing with
this work as with the passengers I'm
going to model this reservation earnings
rate is iid across the drivers so
similarly you can work out what is the
actual rate at which drivers enter
there's some exogenous rate drivers will
enter if their earnings you know desired
kind of reservation earnings rate is is
lower than what they think they're going
to make in you know per unit time and so
expected earnings divided by expected
time okay you don't have to worry too
much about the fact that the expected
czar both the numerator and denominator
here there's sort of a waltz identity
argument that lets you do away with that
passenger model yeah oh yeah sorry
that's a great point so so you're right
this is not the number of rides that
actually gets served this is a number of
ride requests and so what will happen is
that if there's no driver there your
ride request will be blocked and it'll
be dropped no but what I mean is might
decision as to whether or not to even
make the request that my available drag
yeah yeah so so that's a really good
point so first of all when I said
earlier that I wasn't dealing with ETA
that's what I meant that I'm not
modeling
so in queueing models where you think
about and you know this is not
necessarily something specific to me I'd
say that this type of trade-off exists
everywhere
let's just think about like so I'm using
a model where essentially the passengers
cost is blocking right they may not get
served well in a real queuing system
like blocking and delay are not
completely dissimilar from each other in
the sense that if I get blocked but that
really is saying is I just have to wait
longer to get done with whatever I want
to get done right
and so I I think like the right there's
two ways you can think about blocking
it's like actually what the cost is it's
I tried to get a ride and I couldn't say
New Year's Eve or you could think about
it as I didn't get the right and that
means I have to wait you know longer to
be able to get a ride and and I think I
think if this is a very very course sort
of 0th order approximation to the right
thing to do and the right thing to do
would be to actually include ETS in the
model and model that yeah that's a good
question okay so that's the drivers so
let me just quickly run through what the
queueing model is basically the queueing
model is now when I be my queueing model
isn't in describing this to you I'm not
going to say anything about why drivers
and passengers are coming in at the
rates that they're coming in they just
are and then let's so I've already told
you that I have some model that's
strategic for how I'll determine the
rate at which rides are requested how
I'll determine the rate at which drivers
actually entered the system now let me
tell you sort of what actually happens
inside the model but those you know
rates of arrival of drivers and
passengers so basically drivers enter at
some rate lambda and when there's a
drivers available ride requests arrive
at some rate which depends on the number
of available drivers that's what we
computed earlier um if a driver is
available the ride is served otherwise
it's blocked rides lasts an exponential
time with mean tau in the network model
this sort of involves a random walk
around the network so it's a little more
complicated than that and after right
completions this is another point where
I think someone could do something
interesting with this so after ride
completion there's some exogenous
probability that the driver signs out or
it becomes available okay so another
thing that could be interesting that you
can do here is make the exit probability
dependent on their experience in the
system for obvious reasons that leads to
a much more complicated game so this is
a you know far simplified version of
that I would say that I'm actually less
sort of concerned about this assumption
that this is exogenous because drivers
are still making entry decisions based
on their kind of expected earnings in
the platform so it's not as if they're
completely ignoring how they're going to
do but I think if you wanted to refine
it a bit you could think about making
this something which is endogenous okay
so that's that's basically the the model
of what's going on and so if you look at
the picture of what's happening here
there's two reasons that there's
available drivers there's either new
entry from the outside world or there's
a driver who was busy who became
available and and came back into the
system who chose not to exit okay so
there's some queue that's
going up and down available drivers
coming in and then when rides are
requested this cue gets served down okay
so a major sort of simplification for us
and one of the reasons for exactly the
lining of the assumptions we had is that
this type of queueing model turns out to
be what's called a Jackson Network and
this is more generally true for the
network model and Jackson networks are
great because they're steady-state
distribution is a product
alright so despite the fact that there's
all these dependencies in the queuing
network the the steady-state
distribution has the property that in
steady state the queue lengths in the
different you know parts of the network
look like they're independent okay so in
particular here what it means is that
the number of available drivers is
something which we have like an exact
expression for the for the for the
steady-state distribution okay so I'll
skip this slide I sorry I won't go
through everything in detail what I mean
is I just want to tell you what an
equilibrium of our system is so an
equilibrium of our system involves
basically saying I connect together the
strategic behavior of the passengers and
drivers the pricing policy and the
queueing model and so what I do is I say
okay let me take the queueing model
compute a steady-state distribution from
it using the steady-state distribution
for every driver I can work out what is
their expected earnings that they'll
make while they're in the system and
what's the expected time they're gonna
live I can use that to then work out
what's the entry rate of drivers and
then for every passenger I can work out
you know sort of for the passenger kind
of the steady-state condition is easy
it's the same one we had before that
passengers will enter as long as the
price is going to be is going to be
lower than their reservation value and
that goes in the entry rate of ride
requests so all this comes back together
again and I need a consistency check
that the steady-state distribution
actually came from these things that I
just computed alright so you can do that
and that's kind of a definition of a
system equilibrium in our model and you
know what we show is that basically as
long as you have very mild regularity
conditions on the system namely among
other things that the price increases
when the number of available drivers
decreases so this is a condition on the
pricing function then equilibria always
exist and their unique under reasonable
sort of smoothness conditions so oh we
go that that is so let me talk about
sort of nicely smooth those conditions
here I mean on the distributions so let
me let me sort of move on to how we want
to use this so I guess you know part
half the talk
is like here's a model that sort of sits
on some knife at knife edge of
tractability and still capturing a bunch
of effects that are important I've
already pointed out to you at least five
or six different ways that I think you
would want to do things to the model to
capture effects that are that are
important in practice that said at least
in our experience thinking about it
adding any one of those things made the
model much harder to work with so in
order to in order to make progress
beyond what we had I think part of the
question is going to be you know where
you get technical simplicity despite
having at it in these communities
additional complications and I think one
thing for us even with the model that we
had that is very helpful is to use
awesome products to simplify the
analysis this is something which is now
by now very standard in in analyzing
these types of matching markets Eric
bhootish and Eduardo Acevedo have a
really nice paper that sort of talks
about some of the things that you can do
using this type of approach so in our
case the the limiting approach that we
use is that we have a sequence of
systems we consider in the end system
I'm basically scaling up the exogenous
rates the arrival rates of passengers
and of drivers and in the end system I
have some pricing policy that's actually
indexed by in okay and I'll talk to you
a little bit about how that how that
works
so in each system this gives rise to a
system equilibrium and we basically
analyze pricing by looking at the
asymptotics of these equilibrium ok so
that's what I'm going to show you I'll
show you a bunch of pictures that
explain what's going on and there's
corresponding theorems behind it so let
me start with static pricing again
static pricing doesn't mean there's a
single multiplier the whole day it means
that I have a predictable uncertainty on
the order of hours or something like
that that I use to set a multiplier but
I don't change the multiplier on the
basis of the exact number of available
drivers that are in the system so but
you should be thinking when I say static
is that idiosyncratic stochastic
fluctuations are not being captured by
the by the dynamic pricing policy so so
in math this means that P of a is a
constant for all a that no matter what
the level of the queue is I'm setting
the same multiplier so there's a theorem
here that you know don't worry about
reading the technical sort of
expressions carefully but here's
basically what's going on what it says
is that you pick the multiplier that
you're going to use at all eh okay once
you've done that then if I scale and
there's there's this should be scaled by
and this should be our n over and its a
scaled completed
it's obviously the rate of completed
rides is going to go to infinity if if n
goes to infinity it's the scaled rate of
completed rides that that's normalized
so if I take our n over n the rate of
completed rides divided by n that has a
really natural sort of interpretation
imagine sort of two unconstrained
systems one in which as a passenger
whenever I request a ride there's always
a driver waiting for me all right and
another in which as a driver whenever I
finish driving there's always a
passenger right there requesting a ride
that I can get matched to okay so in one
of them demand is not a canoe in the
first system I just described supply is
not a constraint the second one demand
is not a constraint so each of these two
sort of naturally give you a supply
curve in a demand curve this expression
is basically how many drivers would
enter if they knew that whenever they
were available there would be a
passenger immediately there for them and
this expression is how many passengers
would enter if they knew that whenever
they requested a ride there would be
immediately be a driver there to serve
them that's the same entry rate we had
before and so that's that's what put is
basically available the throughput is a
min of available supply and available
demand so that's really nice because you
can visualize it as sort of a demand and
supply curve crossing each other this
green curve here is the demand curve
this green curve here is the supply
curve they cross right at this point now
what's the x-axis this is different than
a usual plot in in economics the x-axis
here is price the y-axis is throughput
so I'll tell you about the red curves in
a second so what I'm saying here is that
you pick a multiplier on the x-axis and
the the actual throughput that you're
going to see in the system is the
minimum of this green curve and this
green curve okay so this sort of pyramid
shape thing is what the overall
throughput is as you vary the multiplier
and you can see that if your only choice
was what multiplier to pick and you
didn't have any dynamic pricing
available the multiplier you would pick
is the one where they intersect right
that's the peak and so that's that's
what we're gonna call that the balance
price for the rest of the talk the red
curves are just depicting what happens
as n increases all right so these are
simulations for finite n and the green
is the theory in the in the limiting
system all right
everybody okay with that so basically
what I'm saying is that there's like a
natural notion of available supply and
available demand and I can use that to
say that if what I want to do is
maximize throughput then the multiplier
would pick is the one
balances the two of them it's pretty
intuitive it's just nice to get that out
of the out of out of the primitives so
I'll skip this slide I just said that so
now let's talk about dynamic pricing and
what we did is we decided to focus on a
particular family of dynamic pricing
policies there's there's a small part of
the paper that says something on
slightly more complex policies but it's
actually it is actually a little bit
harder to deal with sort of arbitrary
dynamic pricing policies and come up
with exactly the same conclusions so
what we do is we focus on threshold
policies and and these are very natural
because they match exactly with what's
done in practice which is basically that
I have a threshold and then if the
number of available drivers drops below
that threshold
I set a multiplier that's a high
multiplier if the number of driver
available drivers goes above that
threshold I set a multiplier that's a
low multiplier okay so I'm kind of
moving between these two multipliers the
slightly more general thing we looked at
is a finite number of thresholds okay
and then you know the more general thing
obviously would be that the the price
curve can be anything across the number
of Avila's and so this has kind of
inspired the reason we specifically
focused on this is because we wanted to
try to say something about what search
and prime-time policies are actually
doing and they basically have this
flavor that there's kind of thresholds
that when they're crossed the the
multiplier is going to go up or down as
a result okay so I think I can convey
kind of what our theorem is with
pictures more easily than the results
I'll show you in a second so let's let
me just sort of parse this picture for
you okay so on the x-axis sorry on the
x-axis what I'm plotting again is the
multiplier right so it's going from from
0 up to 5 here that's the price
multiplier that I'm going to use the
blue curve is the throughput that I
obtain if I just set that multiplier
regardless of the number of available
drivers same basically as the curves
that were showing you in the previous
graph which is pure static pricing okay
the purple curve is what I get with a
very particular dynamic pricing policy
the dynamic pricing policy is one where
one of the two multipliers is set at
green at this at this point right here
and the other multiplier is the one
that's bearing on the x-axis okay now
what does that mean if I'm on this side
then
it means is that the high multiplier is
this value and the low multiplier is
down here and if I'm on this side it
means that the low multiplier is this
value and high multiplier is the one on
this axis that make sense okay so that's
that's kind of how you can do a 1d
visualization of a family of dynamic
pricing policies in this graph and
that's also why there's a kink right
here okay so this then the purple curve
is the throughput that I get with that
particular dynamic pricing policy as I
vary on the x-axis and what I'll do is
I'll just make n larger and as n gets
larger what you notice is what you
should see is that the static curve and
the dynamic curve the peaks are going to
come together okay and so that's what
happens in the limit here so this this
is the limiting value with n going to
infinity the purple curve is what I get
from dynamic pricing again defined the
way that I talked about it where this is
one of the two prices and the other
price is varying on the x-axis and the
blue curve is the one I just showed you
a few minutes ago which is what I get
from static pricing and what's the
important point to notice from this
graph is that both of them coincide at
their peak okay so what that's basically
saying is that in the fluid limit and
this in this kind of hydrodynamic limit
where we're scaling you know down by n
that you're not getting anything by
using a dynamic pricing policy over a
static pricing policy you know there's a
bunch of suppressed in these graphs okay
number one it's numeric so obviously I
haven't convinced you about other
potential values for prices that I could
use number two I didn't say anything
about the threshold right so like what's
going on with the threshold and so in
I'll show you the theorem in a second
one of one of the things we're doing in
the background here is that as n is
getting larger we're varying the
threshold that we use and we're doing so
in an optimal way given the two prices
that are chosen right so we're kind of
favorably biasing the dynamic pricing
policy to pick the best threshold that
we could given the two prices that were
used and so really the result is saying
here is feel free to pick the threshold
and the two prices however you want and
you're never gonna do better than what
what static pricing gets you yeah okay
now B I should be done before that
already okay so this is the limit and
what it basically says is let our n star
be the rate of completed rides in the n
system using the optimal static price
and let our n double star be the rate of
completed rise in the n system using the
optimal threshold pricing strategy
then if the valuation distribution has a
monotone hazard rate I'll talk more
about this in a second then the the
difference between these two scaled by n
goes to zero okay so some comments on
this first of all I want to point out so
there's this is a really important
restriction in the result and the proof
of the result what ends up happening is
that we need to look at sort of how the
level of demand changes as you vary the
pricing policy and it turns out that
some condition on the valuation
distribution is is sort of necessary
it's a little bit looser than this it
doesn't quite have to be that strong
that that's probably most interpretable
definition what's interesting is that
there's no condition on the on the
Preferences of the drivers FC does not
enter into this theorem so FC could be
arbitrary it's the the restriction is
only on that fee okay that's one point
the second point is I guess what I find
interesting about this result it the way
I would state it I I think like the the
more glib statement is there's no value
to dynamic pricing I think the way I
would stated that's a bit more precise
is that there's only second-order
benefit to dynamic pricing right so to
the extent that you see benefits from
dynamic pricing it's happening because
it's happening because you're actually
able to sort of correct things in the in
the sort of a Gaussian term not in the
not in the fluid term the third comment
I want to make is that maybe one naive
view you might have on this result as
well of course because you took the
limit you got rid of all stochasticity
but the thing is that's not true so that
the drivers went there is actually a
well-defined steady state distribution
that's seen sorry/not drivers by
passengers when they enter even in the
limiting system okay so when a passenger
arrives it is the case that the the
number of available drivers that they
see is a random variable and that
remains true even when you pass to the
limit okay so it's it is true that we're
speeding up the system but from a
passengers perspective they're always
reacting an instantaneous state so that
stochasticity is still relevant and then
i think that's part of what makes the
makes the fact that this happens a
little bit surprising
so one comment i want to make is that
these types of results are similar to
stuff that's kind of long-standing in
the revenue management literature where
in the early results in that literature
you know it was established that that
fluid pricing policies of the sort that
we were talking about are not going to
be better than dynamic pricing
and there's been a lot of work extending
those types of results but one
interesting thing in that literature is
they're not really been any work that
looks at two-sided markets so that
literature usually what happens is
you're kind of given a fixed basket of
stuff to sell and then you're allowed to
use whatever mechanism you want to sell
up to a deadline and like the canonical
example is airline tickets so you're an
airline you're selling seats and so you
have like planes that are empty and you
have a bunch of seats to sell up to a
deadline when the plane actually takes
off you're allowed to use whatever
pricing policy you want to set prices
for the seats okay in our case kind of
one of the things I think that makes
this really interesting is that we have
this you know that the seats are
strategic the seats are the drivers and
and they're they're entering because of
because of what we're doing so you know
that's one of the big differences and so
again just to point out kind of why this
is interesting to work on is I think
there are if you look at the problems
that are faced by many platforms in
managing inventory internally so the
analog in air B&B would be sort of
managing the inventory of hotel rooms
they look like classic revenue
management problems but with strategic
supply and so that that you know that
perspective is something which opens up
I think a range of algorithmic insight
that isn't there yet in the literature
so I'm going to skip the proof just
because we're already well over time for
this session I'm happy to talk to you
about that offline if you want or if you
play back the video and look at the
slide slowly you should be able to make
it out so last thing I'll tell you is
and this result I think is less
surprising it's just I just like it
because of the nature of how we
formulated it so dynamic pricing is
obviously helpful all right and and
already there's a hint in this
second-order effect that I mentioned and
really like why do we use it well one
reason we use it is because we don't
want to have to sit and futz around with
what we think the system parameters are
actually going to be even when it's
predictable uncertainty all right so one
thing that's nice about dynamic pricing
is it sort of naturally adjusts itself
to wherever the system is living okay
and somehow you would like to be able to
make a statement that that captures that
robustness that if the system parameters
are known yeah then maybe static pricing
is at least as good as there never is
you know doing as good as dynamic
pricing but when system parameters are
unknown presumably you should gain
something in robustness because you were
using a dynamic pricing policy so there
are a lot of different ways to give
these kinds of robustness results and
again in the revenue management
literature it usually involves taking
the second-order limit like looking at a
fusion limit of the system and there
those are nice but but definitely
technically complex what we want to do
is take maybe a more of a robust
optimization viewpoint where we
basically said let's ask can we get sort
of dynamic pricing to be near optimal
across a wide range of system parameters
okay
so again I'll just tell you that the
result in pictures so here what I'm
doing is I'm picking one of the
parameters let's say the exoticness
arrival rate of passengers and of you
know app opens and what I'm plotting
here is this is the throughput I would
get if regardless of what the you know
for each value the system parameter I
set the optimal static price okay this
is the blue curve is what I get if I set
the optimal strategy for static price
believing that the exogenous rate of
customer arrivals was mutant was a 4.0
but in fact it ended up being something
different and so yeah right here
obviously it's it's optimal but then it
really degrades quickly as I move away
right well you really want like is the
difference between these two things now
suppose that what I tell myself is okay
you know I don't know what me zero is
going to be exactly but I think it's
gonna be between three point six and
four point four so let me take each of
those to compute the corresponding
static prices for each of those to the
optimal static prices and use these two
as the two prices in a dynamic pricing
scheme okay
again buried in the background is what
threshold do I set to move between these
two and I'll just tell you that that
we're using the same sort of optimality
result that was in the proof to be able
to set that threshold between once you
give me the two prices I can set the
optimal threshold right and what you
find is that if you now plot how dynamic
pricing does using these two prices the
two prices from the extremes then yeah
it degrades badly outside of that
uncertainty set but inside the
uncertainty set and what we can show is
that dynamic pricing always gets you at
least the linear interpolation between
these two optimal values okay and at
least in the numerical experiments we've
done that tends to be quite good this
the the green curve is is concave and
all the experiments we've looked at so
far numerical experiments so basically
the point is the result we have is
something which characterizes the
robustness of dynamic pricing through
this notion of an uncertainty set over
system parameters and says that you
always do at least as well as the linear
interpolation from the endpoints of your
uncertainty set and this
kind of a technical statement of that
okay so let me conclude so a bunch of
different things that we were trying to
do in this in this work and so some
things I didn't you know managed to get
to network modeling with multiple
regions when I say our main insights
generalize I mean they generalize sort
of to the extent that we're you know
able to characterize this difference
between static and dynamic pricing we
haven't accounted for ETA sort of in the
way that David asked about right
aggregate welfare is something like I
said numerically we get very similar
insights but but we're trying to work
the theory out there and I think it
really gets interesting when you start
changing you know when you start asking
you know much more foundational design
questions so one thing that that I think
Chris even pointed out is that you know
you can imagine showing drivers these
heat maps where we're saying like here
is a place where there's there's more or
less demand available we have some model
inside the queueing model we've we've
come up with some nice sort of tractable
ways to deal with this but extending it
then to add in the strategic the
strategic component has not been so easy
but I think that again this is a really
important direction to take the work
it's be structure changing the
percentage we talked about already and
finally I think that there's sort of
changing the matching algorithm there's
something which has really not discussed
a lot if you ask you know uber or lyft
I'm sure they would say that they want
it to be fairly transparent so you're
match to the nearest driver there's all
kinds of really good reasons why you
might want to manage inventory very
differently across the network
especially if you for those of you that
were here for the industry the reverse
field trip day you know they were
talking about this sort of you know
tessellation of the earth into smaller
regions than what they've been using
before and once you start doing that I
absolutely think you would want your
match algorithm to occasionally pick
people from adjacent regions you know
depending on you know or another example
this would be the Chris on Monday
mentioned that uber wants to be able to
accommodate driver preferences it use
either Chris or last week that if a
driver says hey I want to be able to be
get back to the East Bay in an hour I'm
gonna accommodate well that's gonna
change the match algorithm you're not
going to give it to the nearest driver
necessarily and I think this is again
one of these things with sort of
geographic matching you would have to
have a good queueing model and you would
have to be able to model the incentives
of the participants recently well so let
me stop there thank you all for coming
and thank you to all the speakers again
so pretty well over time so maybe if
there's one or two questions but
otherwise we can wrap up here yeah why
don't we stop okay
thanks I really for actually being yeah
yeah yeah that's